- Cinq ans de gestation pour que
cette maison voie le jour sur
un terrain donné par la Ville
de Varennes, en Montérégie,
pour des familles comme
celle d'Alexandra.
NICOLAS GILBERT,
frère d'Alexandra
- C'est ma grande soeur,
mais je la considère comme
ma petite soeur. Elle est
tellement précieuse à mes yeux,
tout le temps en train de rire.
SOPHIE MASSICOTTE,
mère d'Alexandra
- Un grand soulagement,
de trouver un endroit
comme celui-là, avec des gens
extérieurs de notre réalité
qui s'implique là-dedans
et qui ont bâti quelque chose
d'aussi beau, c'est merveilleux.
LOUIS MORISSETTE
- On se répétait toujours :
il y a une cause
qui a besoin de nous.
- Voici donc un milieu de vie
complètement adapté aux
particularités sensorielles
des adultes autistes.
VÉRONIQUE CLOUTIER, admin.
Fondation Véro & Louis
- Il y a beaucoup d'attention
qui a été mise sur le son, sur
la lumière, parce que ce sont
des choses qui peuvent irriter
les personnes autistes.
On a l'exemple des miroirs
dans la salle de bains,
il y en a qui ont peur
carrément, car ça déclenche
une crise de voir le reflet,
donc les miroirs ont été
camouflés dans des armoires.
- Et c'est sûr qu'il y a
des familles vont venir.
- Tous les espaces communs
sont au rez-de-chaussée.
Salon et salle d'activités,
une grande cuisine
et deux salles à manger.
- Et puis de l'autre côté,
c'est plus tranquille.
- En haut, les chambres.
Il y en a 20 en tout,
formant 5 grappes
autour d'un petit salon.
Elle a été construite et
aménagée au coût de 5 millions
de dollars par la Fondation
Véro & Louis, mais c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une maison.
KATTY TAILLON, directrice
générale, Fondation Véro & Louis
- C'est vraiment un milieu de
vie, on est bien encadré...
c'est pas juste dans la
surveillance, on est vraiment
dans une programmation
qui éducative.
- Ce sera donc un environnement
stimulant grâce aux services
dispensés par le réseau
de la santé, qui sera
aussi responsable de choisir
les résidents parmi ceux
qui attendent un hébergement.
- On comprend ce que vous voulez
faire. Bon, comment on s'arrange
pour que ca puisse fonctionner?
- Une bonne idée de départ
soutenue par l'expertise
clinique et la recherche
universitaire.
- C'est tout à fait audacieux,
je vous dirais aussi, donc
les projets de recherche vont
vraiment nous aider à démontrer
l'aspect novateur et si ça donne
les resultats escomptés,
c'est ce qu'on souhaite et
c'est ce qu'on veut vraiment,
puis ça va sûrement ouvrir
la porte vers d'autres
modèles d'hébergement.
- Les besoins sont grands,
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui,
on ouvre la première maison,
mais j'espère que c'est
le début d'une grande aventure
et qu'il y aura des dizaines
de maisons à travers le Québec.
- Partout, oui!
C'est parti d'un livre
que Ghislaine a écrit.
- C'est tout ce dont rêvait
celle qui élève deux garçons
autistes.
- C'est important pour moi
qu'il y ait de la joie, autant
pour les gens qui travaillent
à la maison, pour les résident,
aussi pour les parents,
à qui ça va amené
une grande paix d'esprit,
et je sais de quoi je parle.
Leur intimité, leur espace...
va être respecté, et c'est
ce qui ressemble le plus...
et je mets entre parenthèses...
à une normalité!
- Ce qu'on pouvait souhaiter
de mieux pour elle, c'est
un endroit et elle pourrait
continuer à s'épanouir quand
nous, on ne sera plus capables.
- À la maison est prête
à accueillir en douceur
ses premiers résidents chez eux.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, V